Trascrizione: Sara Lobasso
Revisore: Simona Donda
La storia del nostro cosmo
e della nostra specie umana
è scandita da eventi, da singolarità
che ne hanno definito sempre nuovi confini
entro cui si è evoluto l’universo.
Questa sera insieme,
attraverseremo alcuni
dei confini del passato
e cercheremo di prevedere
alcuni dei confini del nostro futuro.
Partiremo da lontanissimo:
14 miliardi di anni fa,
il Big Bang.
Quale immagine scegliereste per
descrivere il Big Bang?
Se cercassimo su internet,
troveremmo immagini come queste.
Ovviamente tutte create da
esseri umani, inventate.
Se chiedeste a me di riflettere sul
Big Bang, l’immagine che sceglierei
probabilmente sarebbe invece questa.
Lo spazio, la massa, il tempo
nacquero con il Big Bang,
le leggi della fisica
nacquero con il Big Bang.
Il teorema di Pitagora
e la legge della relatività di Einstein
nacquero con il Big Bang.
Non avevano alcun significato prima,
dato che non esistevano
lo spazio e il tempo.
Poi 300.000 anni dopo il Big Bang,
la materia e l’energia iniziarono
a combinarsi in atomi
e poi gli atomi in molecole.
La storia di queste particelle,
i confini che ne regolano il comportamento
sono oggi chiamati chimica.
La chimica nacque quindi in quel momento.
Tutto ciò avveniva 14 miliardi di anni fa.
Trascorsero quindi 10 miliardi di anni.
Poi, 4 miliardi di anni fa,
su un piccolo pianeta chiamato Terra,
queste molecole iniziarono a combinarsi
fra di loro in modo ancora più evoluto
creando delle strutture molto complesse
chiamati organismi.
Nasceva così la biologia e la vita.
Biologia che non aveva alcun significato,
che non esisteva prima di allora,
almeno sul pianeta Terra e
biologia con le sue leggi,
che ha governato
l’evoluzione di tutte le specie viventi
lungo le epoche geologiche
del nostro pianeta.
Poi due milioni e mezzo di anni fa
accadde qualcosa
di estremamente importante per tutti noi.
Sul nostro pianeta iniziarono a vivere una
serie di specie umane molto simili
a quelli che noi siamo oggi.
Più di 10 specie umane diverse vissero
contemporaneamente sul pianeta Terra
talvolta in convivenza pacifica
e talvolta in conflitto fra di loro.
Poi, una singola specie umana,
l’Homo sapiens sapiens
ebbe la meglio su tutti gli altri.
Noi diventammo i dominatori
di questo pianeta.
Il motivo di ciò
è abbastanza facile da capire.
Come mai l’Homo sapiens sapiens
divenne il dominatore del pianeta, noi.
La nostra incredibile bellezza.
Il nostro fascino.
Quello che avvenne in realtà è che
gli Homo Sapiens Sapiens
iniziarono a costruire delle tribù,
dei gruppi evoluti poi delle nazioni,
delle società.
E tutto questo avvenne
grazie a una singola cosa: il linguaggio,
la capacità di fare narrazione
come quello che sto facendo ora io con voi
perché solo raccontando storie,
condividendo delle storie
noi possiamo creare delle
nazioni, delle società,
dei gruppi di ricerca,
dei gruppi scientifici.
Iniziò quindi allora un progresso
sempre più veloce, sempre più rapido;
12.000 anni fa la rivoluzione agricola,
5.000 anni fa la scrittura,
500 anni fa la rivoluzione scientifica,
200 anni fa
la prima rivoluzione industriale,
la seconda rivoluzione industriale,
la terza rivoluzione industriale,
l’energia nucleare, l’elettronica,
la genetica, la biotecnologia
e ovviamente l’informatica,
con tutto quello che ne consegue.
Siamo quindi arrivati a oggi.
9 luglio 2021 a Mestre.
E potrei chiedervi con quali
immagini descrivereste l’oggi.
Oggi dove in Cina, Xiaoice,
un algoritmo di intelligenza artificiale,
oltre ad avere conversazioni telefoniche
con milioni di cinesi,
con 660 milioni di follower,
è una delle poetesse più lette al mondo
visto che scrive e pubblica
libri di poesie.
“Sunshine” è l’ultimo che ha pubblicato.
Xiaoice che adatta libri per bambini,
fa analisi finanziarie,
fa tantissime attività.
È una compositrice musicale, una cantante,
addirittura Xiaoice,
perché sia un’intelligenza artificiale,
simula il respiro umano quando canta
così da sembrare più naturale.
Xiaoice che conduce
una trasmissione televisiva in Cina
e che, a un determinato orario la mattina,
conduce 18 trasmissioni radiofoniche
in Cina in parallelo.
Non ha problemi di parallelismo.
Oggi dove potete tutti voi,
usando una tecnologia
come il DNA, la genetica,
pensare, sperare di allungare
sempre più la vostra vita
con i progressi che si stanno facendo,
lavorando sul DNA
potremo personalizzare la medicina,
sconfiggere molte delle malattie
che oggi ancora ci affliggono,
come il tumore.
E con il DNA si sta lavorando
inoltre sul DNA sintetico
come forma di salvataggio
delle informazioni
per utilizzare la codifica del DNA
in sostituzione a 0 e 1
dell’informatica classica.
Ci si aspetta che in un cm³
di DNA sintetico
potremo salvare più informazioni
di quelle contenute
in tantissimi data center
in luoghi sparsi per il pianeta Terra.
Si sta anche già lavorando
col DNA sintetico
come forma di elaborazione
delle informazioni,
come alternativa
ai computer classici di oggi.
Oggi, dove potete,
usando della realtà mista
vedere degli ologrammi e degli oggetti
fisici che interagiscono fra di loro.
Oggi dove già esistono degli occhi bionici
connessi direttamente
alla corteccia cerebrale.
che presto avranno delle performance
superiori all’occhio umano,
a livello ad esempio
di visione al buio o di zoom.
Piuttosto che oggi dove ci sono già
delle braccia robotiche,
delle mani robotiche capaci di maneggiare
gli oggetti come la mano umana.
Piuttosto che oggi dove potete
già ingerire delle pillole
che contengono delle telecamere,
dei robot miniaturizzati
per fare alcune attività
nel mondo della sanità.
Potete immaginare come questo apre
un futuro incredibile
nel mondo della salute
ma soprattutto direi oggi
dove i computer più piccoli,
i transistor più piccoli
sono già 500 volte più piccoli
di una molecola di sangue.
Siamo vicini ai computer quantistici,
ci sono già dei prototipi.
Ci si aspetta,
a livello di comunità scientifica
che con il computer quantistico
potremo processare in minuti
o forse in secondi, degli algoritmi
che con i migliori computer di oggi
necessiterebbero di più della
vita dell’universo per essere elaborati.
Quindi tutto ciò oggi.
E di fronte a tutto questo oggi,
quale domani possiamo prevedere?
Quale immagine avete dal futuro?
Io mi rendo conto che
parlare di intelligenza artificiale,
DNA sintetico, quantum computing
può anche fare preoccupare
e magari l’immagine
che vi è venuta in mente
può essere una come questa
o più realisticamente questa.
Però, onestamente oggi
se è giusto essere preoccupati
dell’Intelligenza Artificiale,
io sono molto più preoccupato onestamente
dell’opposto dell’intelligenza artificiale
che è la stupidità naturale.
La stupidità con cui potranno utilizzare
queste tecnologie
in modo totalmente sbagliato.
E se non fosse questa
l’immagine del futuro?
Mi chiedo se invece
potrebbe essere quest’altra.
E non è un nostro cugino primate
che sta fumando qualcosa di illecito,
né è un richiamo
al “Pianeta delle scimmie”,
altro film cult del XXI° secolo.
Questo, in realtà,
è Pager, un macaco maschio
che ha imparato a giocare a
questo videogioco chiamato Mind Pong
usando il joystick che vedete ha in mano,
senonché il joystick, Pager non lo sa,
è stato scollegato dal videogioco
quindi Pager senza saperlo
sta comandando il videogioco
usando il proprio pensiero
grazie a dei microprocessori
che sono stati installati
nel suo cervello.
Ma non so nemmeno se questo è il futuro.
Probabilmente no.
Io onestamente credo che il futuro
non assomigli a nessuno
di tutti i film di fantascienza
che abbiamo recentemente visto.
Io sono invece convinto che il futuro
sia quello che vi mostrerò
nella prossima slide.
Questo io voglio credere
sarà il nostro futuro.
Queste bambine che sono oggi
qua in mezzo al pubblico fra di voi
anche se non vogliono essere indicate.
Voi che mi state ascoltando,
perché quelle che io ho condiviso
in questi dieci minuti
sono delle traiettorie tecnologiche,
sono delle innovazioni
che stanno accadendo,
che accadranno magari anche
più rapidamente di quello che immaginiamo.
Ma ancora per tantissimi anni
saremo noi a crearle
soprattutto saremo noi
a decidere quando usarle,
quando non usarle e perché usarle.
In questo caso,
davvero dobbiamo sempre ricordarci
che il modo migliore
per predire il futuro.
è quello di crearlo
e tocca solamente a noi,
tocca solamente a voi,
creare il futuro.
Ed è fondamentale nel fare ciò
essere protagonisti
nella creazione del futuro
per evitare che qualcun altro
ne definisca i confini al nostro posto.
Grazie mille.